good morning
good morning
today we are going to go
to breakfast and
on a little hike that's right yay
can you explain your outfit to me monkey
then i i pick this this and this
okay so why did you pick the watch
what's up with the watch
i'm after my shirt
blessed you
bless you oh jesus we'll be right back
okay we're back no more boogies okay so
tell me about the watch
so you have the watch because it matches
your shirt so are you telling me that
this watch is a teenage mutant ninja
turtle watch
oh what is does it your watch do
anything special oh yeah
oh it lights up and these are neither of
our turtles that's the turtle one this
one in the middle this one doesn't work
doesn't do anything oh it doesn't do
anything
or the metal one okay can you tell me
what time it is it's time for it
for me to get a watch
yeah okay it's time for me to get a
watch uh okay so what about the t-shirt
where'd you get the t-shirt from from
i'm gonna get it i just got it for my
birthday oh for your birthday who got it
for you
[Music]
who
who gave it to you i don't know oh
i gave it to you
how'd you
got it
i bought it at the store
i was sleepy yeah
i keep a lot of secrets from you dude
okay we're back um what about those
shorts how come you went with gray
not black not red not blue white gray
good answer and then you wanted black
socks instead of white socks why
because you said no white socks well i
said no white socks when you're walking
around the house because you're gonna
dirty the white socks
but you can wear white socks with your
shoes
well we're like black socks i don't like
black why do you like black so much
black is my favorite color how come it's
your favorite
my whiter color that's my favorite color
black yeah okay black is a good color
color is that a hat
yep how'd you got it i brought it for
you because i'm awesome you're magic
i am a magician
a magic magician thank you so much
don't forget it
okay so don't mind the hat i was copying
type of style
i normally wear my hats this way and i
like this one it was sent to me or it
was gifted
by peacock the tv network for the show
um
joe and carol and it's it's about the
tiger king and all that but
um yeah i just like that it said
easy tiger
because anything tiger-related as you
know i
link it with taika because taiko means
tiger and this is my little tiger right
here
hi tiger
oh okay his name is monkey okay um so we
are in route
and we're yes you're my monkey cheeto we
are in route to get some
american breakfast right is it american
breakfast yep american diner breakfast
american diner breakfast
he's gonna get his red velvet pancakes
and then we're gonna go on a little
hiking hike but today's gonna be kind of
interesting because it's super windy and
taika is still a little bit scared or a
lot scared of the wind i'm nervous
you're never scared
my bad tyka is never scared what am i
talking about i can't believe i just
said the wrong thing i'm sorry i'm just
kidding
okay he's never scared but he is scared
of tornadoes we got it
it could be like
yeah tornadoes are definitely dangerous
it's okay an update but there's a love
to us tycho is never scared but he is
scared of tornadoes so we got that
well today's windy but monkey
there is no tornadoes in nevada
[Music]
yeah there's no elephant purple turtles
they're just usually tomatoes oh there's
different tornadoes they're not a
different color they're the same colors
yeah they're the same color but just not
different colors yeah but there's
difference true okay so yeah that's what
our day looks like oh and obviously but
tornadoes can make french
tornadoes connect sweat yeah
true well don't even let me introduce
you to tsunamis because
and that's a black monster and then
you're fighting each other
[Music]
how do you know these things that is a
lamborghini
i
i i saw a blue one okay so right here we
are at
rise and shine a steak and egg place i
love it
when the name
tells you exactly what you're getting
yourself into
it's predictable it's thoughtless
and
that's what i need in my life right now
there's too much unpredictable
unpredictability and a lot of thought
right now and i want to i want i want to
stop all that so i love that my
breakfast is not making me do that you
know what i mean
what the hell you have four eggs sausage
and a what kind of waffle is that it's a
waffle so thank you so when i was in
texas i was eating waffles with nadine
and it was so good and i've been
thinking about waffles ever since yeah
and that's why did you hear the first
thing i asked is are your waffles crispy
because like rascals it's all flimsy
right yeah so that's as soon as it came
out i went like this
yes okay but i'm more interested in the
four eggs dude i love ants i'm a big
expert you really like the eggs i
thought you would only get it because of
the protein well that's when i get egg
whites
but i like eggs what about it oh yo the
yolk it's like just so savory it's fatty
and it's like slimy it's like so good
that's the reason why people don't like
the yolk i know and that's why they're
done but i love i love look at this look
at this dumbbell i love it when they put
like that green stuff on there what is
it what does that mean
or something
beautiful
did it pop in your mouth
i could literally eat it every day no
way
i didn't know that about you you looked
yeah
i loved it i literally thought it was
just because of the proteins i love eggs
with soy sauce
with salt and pepper i had no idea
we need a divorce and we need to start
dating all over again whoa
whoa
so we have a little dilemma here taika
ordered these delicious
red velvet pancakes
but
so delicious before he can have them he
has to eat some protein
and a little bit of uh what is this
called
and they are potatoes yes and papa's
giving him some eggs
but taika's been chewing on that
piece for how long
for 500 minutes
preventing him from eating these
delicious look at this they're warm the
chocolate is melted
then you still have the same amount open
your mouth
oh my god
there's some water
wash it down let's go dude i want you to
eat your pancakes
look at that thing is still in your
mouth
[Music]
you still have egg in your mouth
but that's the last of it because now
papa's hooking them up
to eat
it
why are you getting my face like that
for you
happy he's a happy boy he's a happy
happy happy boy
look at that
how many times have you had to tell him
to eat his food not once
how many times after you tell them to
chew not once
[Music]
okay so i think allergies are picking
back up because psycho keeps sneezing
and every time he sneezes there's a
crap ton of snot that comes out
and i never have tissue
i feel like i just finished it the
previous time and i just don't have
enough time to refill it so we stopped
by elberton's and picked up
a big old box
that's more
of
late tissue it's a dad car for sure why
because look it's so cool and then you
got that
actually it's never been cool because it
has all these good stuff in there
then that doesn't make it a dad car
dads don't have [ __ ] for their kids
at least my dad didn't want that's true
yeah that's where my dad had a
secondhand smoke waiting for mood about
yours
my dad had sawdust
yeah my dad's
rusty nails everywhere my dad's truck
was full of cigarette butts talents
how's my mom stress them out
[Music]
the wind's taking pop away
oh no monkey what are we gonna do
do we need a new papa i think i told you
i was taking it
yeah should we get a new look he's
coming back
[Laughter]
oh no he's gone again
do you want to get a new papa i think
okay do you want to go pick any papa
a tornado take him away yeah are you
happy
what that we have a new papa everybody i
mean the tornado took away papa
are you happy that the tornado took papa
yeah i need her yeah nobody needs that
guy he's a bad boy he's a family i'll
take you tonight go outside hey you want
me to get rid of me too
yeah i want to be myself
okay
[Music]
monkey you look so cool with these
shades on
oh my god okay okay let's go ahead let's
go hike
it's so windy
back in the car and was definitely not
gonna vlog that because i couldn't vlog
that because it was just so windy
it was so windy but trust me you guys
didn't miss out on much it was just like
a dirt road i was so proud of tyka
though it was the windiest he's ever
felt and he walked by himself for five
minutes yeah usually he's like i'm
afraid of the widow for the widow and
he's crying and he's trying to hold on
our hand but we keep telling him to face
his fears
so he's been super brave and he still
goes out and he still plays and he still
does everything but he's still very much
apprehensive
when doing so and he'll like
he'll like get hot try to hide a little
bit and he'll run to hold her hand so we
told him this time
that he should face his fears for five
minutes and not hold our hand and you
did it dude how was that
how was it for the five minutes that you
couldn't hold on to her hand what were
you thinking
but what were you thinking monkey tell
me baby's tired
he could see himself that's probably why
he's entertained but holy group what are
we doing now
go home
are we going home
no no affection infection okay so he had
this metal rod in his hand and said he
couldn't bring it because if he cuts
himself and this metal rod is slightly
dust uh rusty he's going to get an
infection so of course that spark does
eat his interest and peaked his interest
so he's like when we get home can we
look at more infections
you're an interesting boy i like it like
that
he likes infections
we are at home depot picking up some
stuff and of course
this dude decides to come dressed in a
spider-man outfit
what spider-man is this again i forget i
want my old maguire
what's my husband
miles mcguire are you sure about that
get off get off
do you want to think about that
as a kid this was always my favorite
wall just because it's so pleasant to
look at and everything's organized and
all the beautiful colors i only wanted
to paint my room and i never could
[Music]
okay we are back home right now and uh
we really need to get the organizing
done as you can see everything is kind
of like
a mess in our room right now
and we told taika yes one second one
second we told taika that um we wanted
to take a chucky cheese cheese today
cheers cheese today if we finish our
work and taika what did you say
yeah you were watching a phone like that
yep so i told them anytime you see mom
and papa not working you're gonna tell
us
every day you're going to say what
what is it
um
and i was just using my phone to read
something and he was like mama get to
work and i was like
you're right sir thank you so much so
i'm gonna get to work no more vlogging
okay get to work please
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
can you tell me which one it what it
sounds like again this one
and these ones
are these ones
[Music]
i like the grumpy one i think that one's
my favorite
[Music]
[Music]
um okay
okay so we're done for the day just kind
of like cleaning things up
moving things around
organizing stuff
tank is over here
this is an absolute [ __ ] fest
throwing away a bunch of stuff
tech is ready where are you going monkey
yeah where are we gonna go
oh yeah
okay so that's what was the plan is to
just organize look at papa's closet you
guys
wow
he did such
a great job
you're dead yeah
but yeah everything is clean
organized
mine uh not so much but at least i hung
up all my clothes so like a ton of
clothes that i hung up
this is ready
yeah
my shoes
i'm running out of bins i need more bins
for my shoes
and then
[Music]
we're gonna move like all this stuff
down clean that office tomorrow
wow
and then we gotta clean this do a bunch
of laundry
and i put a lot of my winter stuff
in bins
or in a bin
because this is my like winner
closet
jacket closet
but um since the grandpa is living with
us i just kind of want him to have
options so he can stay here if he wants
or guests
um this is my old makeup desk
it's not really a makeup desk it's just
a desk i don't know i don't think i like
it i'm gonna have to move it downstairs
in the meantime
as a placeholder
for when the new furniture comes but i
might i rather it's so ugly in here i
think i'm just i'd rather have it be
empty
okay so as promised we are taking tekken
to play some games however we're just
not going to go to chuck e cheese
because those games are kind of whack so
we decided to come to red rock
it's super windy but what'd you say
some games are broken he says yeah some
games are broken so we decided to come
to red rock get some dinner out here
honestly this is the [ __ ]
we're gonna eat at hearthstone
and then we're gonna go to an arcade out
here
what i love about red rock is that you
can enter the um restaurants from the
outside and it makes it super family
friendly out here even though yes it's
still a casino it really does center
around
family
so
we love coming here it's newer also
um no smoking or i guess there's
designated smoking areas so it doesn't
smell all smoky and your cane is just so
cute in here and again new the dog oh
your dad whoa is that usher is that
michael jackson
whoa
[Music]
so change of plans we actually got
pizza and a root beer
from cypress what a freaking dope it's a
dope and the pizza looks legit
what's that guys
yeah so we're gonna eat oh and then papa
had a great idea of getting wings so
we're going to wing stop so it's
wingstop
right now they're making so chicken and
wings
wait chicken wings pizza and wings
but this they're both like the best of
the best which is awesome
i can't wait
oh man i can't wait
way better than chuck e cheese i'm so
glad
what have you done look at this we got
lemon pepper
garlic parmesan my two flavored favorite
flavors from wing stock and fries oh my
gosh
okay and we still have the root beer
right how's your pizza so far
oh yeah
it's big yeah i mean you're doing it
you're gonna finish it i think
these fries are good that was a really
nice seasoning
this is why you want me to vlog you
is that it can i stop vlogging you know
no don't put it on your head
okay can i stop vlogging you now yeah
okay
[Music]
i think taika is cold
you're sonic because you're a bowling
ball
[Music]
so is this better than chuck e cheese
dude
oh yeah so we're here inside of red rock
this is called i think kids quest
look at this
i'll do this one okay monkey you're
gonna play this in college okay
but you know when you get older
it's not gonna be like this it's gonna
be way more fun dude way more fun
okay let's go duty game number one
there you go
oh man come on dude come on dude
you can do better come on
aim for the middle
[Applause]
[Music]
you're good now are you kidding me
you want to get a lot of points dude
all right taika he loves this game he
said
let's see
good job
he's definitely your son
oh my god
nothing
you're done duty
i don't even know how this game works
this thing was crazy
all right papa
show them what you got
show what you got rusty grandpa
let papa let papa
solo
there you go whoa
careful monkey
oh
sorry
oh my god taika
wait wait
[Music]
[Music]
oh it's like his first roller coaster
[Music]
[Music]
oh oh no it fell out
you're so funny
[Music]
so taika got some putty what else did
you get
a car
two aliens
yes
okay so i made a mistake when i said
that red rock was smoke-free or had
smoking areas no that's not the case uh
definitely they smoke everywhere but
that's how great the ventilation is that
you rarely smell it
and on that now we're leaving
which means we're going home
which means we're gonna go home and lay
down which means i have to end this vlog
so thank you guys so much for watching
and we'll see you guys tomorrow